like just having a stranger touch me all
over my body
I wasn't ready for it and it just
brought up all this trauma and I started
crying that day Laverne Cox is speaking
out to ET about her traumatizing
experience at the airport the orange is
the new black star recently made
headlines after an alleged pat-down by
the TSA made her feel quote unsafe it
was deeply traumatising for me it
probably is for others and other folks
as well and I think part of it was no
fleet part of it was just sort of
stressful day and so it was just really
emotional having a stranger go through
every article of my clothing but that is
what I'm not the only person who's gone
through that when I tweeted about it it
was amazing that so many people
responded with similar experiences a lot
of trans folks have had M experiences
like that I don't think this had to be
with me being trans specifically but
yeah it was deeply traumatizing but I'm
over it I've done the work and I'm ready
for the next time it happened